the era of marvel video games is looking
bright as multiple developers and
publishers have several games in
development the next one is marvel's
guardians of the galaxy a new title from
developer idos montreal and publisher
square enix with the team behind this
decade's deus ex games and shadow of the
tomb raider at the helm expectations are
naturally high for this cosmic caper
starring the galaxy's most recognizable
a-holes it's really all that you think
of rodent no i also think about bombs
and booze so here's everything you need
to know about the game for more
guardians make sure to like this video
and subscribe
idos montreal has kept its cards close
to its chest about the story but what is
known is that guardians picks up several
years after a cataclysmic war took place
throughout the galaxy the damage dealt
by that conflict was devastating and
when we joined the gang they're a group
of heroes for hire who are barely held
together by their common interests good
of you to join us
what's the harm oh let's just pay our
fine naturally things get worse for the
team when they set off a chain of
catastrophic events eventually leading
to a wild ride across space to fix their
mess taking inspiration from the mcu
square enix and idos montreal's version
of the guardians of the galaxy is made
up of the most bankable and familiar
incarnation of the group peter starlord
quill leads a motley crew that includes
drax the destroyer gamora the deadliest
woman in the galaxy the grumpy rocket
who's definitely not a raccoon
definitely not a raccoon and the
eco-friendly groot seeing as how this is
the intergalactic arm of the marvel
universe recent trailers have shown off
a few other faces that include the nova
corps and most importantly the best dog
in the entire galaxy cosmo fun fact to
accurately create the canine cosmonaut
who wields vast psionic powers as the
security chief of nowhere idos montreal
outfitted a real dog by the name of
diego in a motion capture suit another
character that idos montreal is teasing
for guardians of the galaxy is him or
more accurately adam warlock while he's
cloaked in shadows in this tweet from
the game's official account warlock
usually takes the appearance of a golden
skinned humanoid with a range of
impressive physical powers we're about
to see a whole lot more of adam warlock
as will poulter will play him in the
upcoming third guardians movie and last
but definitely not least fan favorite
character mantis will also be making an
appearance an occasional member of the
team in her comic book and film
appearances idos montreal's version of
the character has a few cosmetic changes
and will likely have a few personality
tweaks as well as the studio has pushed
to make its version of the marvel
universe feel familiar but unique
[Music]
guardians need villains to protect the
galaxy from and so far it looks like
there'll be two heavyweights in that
division to keep an eye on first
introduced last year lady hellbender is
a deadly adversary when crossed and has
earned the title of monster queen in her
arm of the cosmos the other sinister
face making an appearance is grand
unifier raker who in the comics has
served as the voice of the church of
truth a militant cardinal of the church
reika had only a handful of appearances
before he met his end at the hands of
drax which has left eidos montreal
plenty of room to put its own spin on
the character five members make up the
guardians of the galaxy but you'll only
play a star-lord throughout the campaign
when engaged in battle star-lord can
whip out his trademark element guns to
deal damage with blaster fire use his
jet boots to maneuver around enemies and
close the distance with melee attacks
where guardians of the galaxy gets
interesting though is in how star-lord
can issue commands to his team which
allow for various combos to be executed
in the heat of battle the team-based
combat allows for a well-oiled unit that
plays to their various strengths groot
is best for crowd control gamora has a
conservative approach to facing enemies
drax takes on as many as he can and
rocket sticks to the rear while
providing covering fire
successfully completing a battle rewards
players with experience and ultimately
ability points which can be used to
unlock new skills for the team there's
even an ultimate morale boost that can
be performed once you have enough
momentum as star-lord calls the team
together into a huddle for a pep talk
pay attention to your team's gripes
rally them together for a final push
when the odds are stacked against them
and you'll be able to unleash them with
increased damage and quicker ability
cooldowns while a hit single from the
1980s plays in the background while
blasting your way through hordes of
intergalactic scum is unavoidable
one other major pillar of gameplay in
guardians of the galaxy is its narrative
and the choices you'll make during the
campaign multiple combat options during
exploration and even combat can have an
impact while other major moments in the
story will have ramifications down the
line choices have consequences with one
notable example early in the game being
when the guardians attempt to pull a con
on lady hellbender by selling her either
groot or rocket as a potential monster
for her collection whichever character
you go with will have an effect on how
the story plays out oh yeah it's about
working time
as for the moments they'll be discovered
when the game arrives it remains to be
seen just how impactful your decisions
will be in the grand scheme of things
guardians of the galaxy is not a live
service game for anyone dreading the
appearance of a season pass the good
news is that idos montreal has focused
on creating a game that is a pure
single-player and offline
narrative-based experience it's a move
that's been met with a positive
reception especially in light of last
year's marvel's avengers guardians of
the galaxy is somewhat unique for the
approach it has taken in the audio
department as not only does it have a
traditional orchestral score and a
licensed awesome mix of 80s chart
toppers it also features an original
rock album created just for the game
marvel has actually already created a
spotify playlist if you want to check
out the soundtrack ahead of time
if you're looking to stream the game and
don't want to get dmcad there's also a
special streamer mode that silences the
licensed music fingers crossed it's not
going to be as awkward as in life is
strange it wouldn't be a marvel game if
guardians of the galaxy didn't reference
its own history with collectible
costumes and there'll be an
intergalactic wardrobe that you can dip
into when those outfits have been
discovered inside of the game a few of
these costumes will also be available as
pre-order bonuses and include a more
traditional set of threads from a more
vintage era of cosmic adventures as well
as outfits based on more modern
appearances of the team and the movies
you won't have to wait too long to start
assembling your favorite gang of escaped
cree experiments and deadly assassins
marvel's guardians of the galaxy arrives
on october 26th for xbox series x and s
xbox one ps5 ps4 and pc we'll have even
more on guardians of the galaxy around
release so make sure to subscribe to get
all the latest i'm on twitter at lucy
james games and i'll catch you next time
you